oui il regarde tout ce qui se passe ok à
la rédaction
sur le plateau sur les fêtes pendant les
coulisses pendant la pub
oh que oui hélas aujourd'hui la
toussaint oui serré hier c'était une
journée spéciale pour moi c'était mon
anniversaire c'était votre anniversaire
eh bien figurez vous que je vous ai
suivi toute la journée à matin au soir
sans vous le voyez un oui au bureau
ouais au plateau ouais au restaurant
ouais j'ai tout vu amer mais croyez moi
un très beau regarder la folle journée
de bail
[Musique]
ce mini cheryl du monde mais trop c'est
trop série d'origine soit et demeure cgt
en revanche du royaume à jogging
si je me suis sentie oppressée qu'en bas
de chez toi je fais ton nom mais
personne dedans temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous partir ensemble puisque c'est mon
anniversaire je vous amène tous au
restaurant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
en fait la plateforme sûr éclater cas si
j'arrêtais pas de la montée on prêtait
redescendre est toujours question du
coût au nom de la rédaction nous offre
un petit cadeau cyril blesson
c'est une norme c'est un truc très
simple puisque et des pantalons le plus
beau
[Applaudissements]